The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: Early on in
Russia, an estimate was made,
and national policy would
provide nine square meters
of private space per person in
housing as an official policy.
This remained throughout,
although it's much lower
than any other European city.
When St. Petersburg
was two million people,
they were still operating on
a nine square meter policy,
even under Khrushchev's
Microraion policy.
Anyway, let's start
with Great Britain.
I'm not that interested
in you following
the details of the case.
I have a bad cold,
and I won't remember
the difference between
Milutin and, well, Melnikov.
Of course I know the difference
between Milutin and Melnikov,
but some of the [? Bart ?]
brothers, and the Vesnin
brothers, and all the
architects and urbanists
who were involved in
this intense period.
There was more examination of
the formal options of cities
between 1919 and 1925 in
Russia in a compressed period
than almost anywhere since.
So it's worth us looking at it,
both as theory and as practice.
Let's look at Great Britain.
Joseph Paxton, the gardener who
designed the Crystal Palace,
said when he proposed the
Victorian way in London, which
was roughly the four by
one and a half square box
in the center of London,
he said, "We in Britain
solve all problems by common
sense and technology."
And that's the
mantra, which precedes
throughout the
British 19th century,
with the intense change being
softened by social policy
changes at the same, in
some curious way providing
enough intellectual
freedom for Marx and Engels
to create a new
political philosophy,
which changed Eastern Europe
and led to the Soviet Union.
Now these relationships
are not that direct,
but nevertheless, had Marx
and Engels been closeted
in Germany, or even
in France, and not
given the intellectual freedom
that they had in England,
the outcomes of the 1918
Revolution in Russia
would have probably
been different.
So here, you have
an intersecting
of two philosophies--
common sense and technology.
You remember my statistics,
that between Peterloo
in Manchester in 1811 and
Bloody Sunday in Northern
Ireland in 19--
god knows when, over
100 years of time--
the British police or the
army only killed something
like 11 people.
That a society could
transform itself
without the state involving
itself in violence
is an incredible
credit to any society.
There are very few places
that could [? end it. ?]
So I said this is a preface to
the British decision in 1946
to embark on a new towns policy.
The earlier years
of the 20th century
had been difficult for England.
13 out of the--
let me put on my glasses--
13 out of the 46 years
between 1899 and 1945,
Britain had been
involved in war.
The number of males who were
killed in the British army--
of course, hardly any women
were in the British army
during this period--
was a high proportion.
You will notice
Victorian novels which
are adumbrated into TV movies
like "Upstairs, Downstairs,"
one of the young men is
always dressed in uniform.
There's a presence of the
military in the British society
which is oscillates from
pop music to hero worship,
preparing Britain for the
worst confrontation of all
between 1939 and 1945.
Add these years of war
to the Depression years,
the international
Depression years,
from early 1930s
onwards, and you
have a country which is engaged
in material affairs which
are not really predominantly
located inside England itself.
In 1946, the Labor
Party wins the election
and decides to retool England.
When I was a student
in England in the '50s
England was barely
off rationing food.
The car population
of England was
what it was in the
United States in 1927.
So the British set out
to work simultaneously
on a number of innovative
ideas about hospitals,
about universities--
and I will show you
some of the university
plans in sequence
in a later class as a
demonstration of how you
experiment with certain notions
about university education,
leading from
categorical campus plans
after Basil Spence in 1950
to the dematerialization
of the physical
structure of universities
in the Loughborough
College example, and so on.
As far as new talent was
concerned, a number of things
were to be taken into account.
First of all, the British had a
history of building new talent.
Letchworth and Welwyn Garden
City by Ebenezer Howard
were both successful,
privately sponsored,
not state interventions at all.
That they should serve as
a model for a new policy
experience is interesting.
It seems to me that
even advanced societies,
such as Great Britain, build
on, in the common sense
and technology model, build step
by step on previous experience,
extrapolating it.
For instance, the new
town's committee report,
government publication, 1946--
let's read what it says about
the size of these new towns.
"Our conclusions as
to the range of size
have been reinforced by the
replies received to a broadcast
on 15th January, 1946."
This is pretty
primitive participation.
This is before television.
"Of those who stated they would
prefer to live in a new town,
the numbers in favor of
20,000, 40,000, and 60,000
were approximately equal,
while only about one in seven
were in favor of towns
under 20,000 or over 60,000.
If you ask a bunch of
people a question like this,
what do you expect?
You expect you will get
a culturally centralized
argument.
Now, number 21--
"why do we believe
the normal range of
population should
be between 30,000 to 50,000?
Special consideration
by the world
may well justify the
creation of a new town
with less than 20,000 people."
What is the population of Welwyn
Garden City and Letchworth,
the target population?
AUDIENCE: The target population?
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: 30.
JULIAN BEINART: 30, Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But they
only got [? 15? ?]
JULIAN BEINART: I don't know
what the population is today.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --not even
half, close to half.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Mark One, Harlow Stevenage,
et cetera, population 30,000,
towns which follow a model of
a center or a single center,
compartment the neighborhood
around it by rail system,
which runs through a
tube parallel to London,
or to Glasgow, to
wherever these towns were,
a modest city center, and a
clear distribution of parts.
The architectural
paradigm at the time
was the 1952, '51, yeah.
New Britain
Exposition in London--
don't worry about
my handwriting.
It's not important.
Mark Two towns were
more experimental.
So these are
attached to the past.
People were starting to wonder,
particularly the architects,
as to what innovations
are possible
beyond this nuclear town.
So you get towns
like Hook Cumbernauld
C-U-M-B-E-R-N-A-U-L-D, Irvine,
and Runcorn, R-U-N-C-O-R-N.
Hook is a town which
established itself in a valley,
so the center of the city
occupies many levels.
And the neighborhoods
are in a linear city,
within walking
distance of the center.
The social engineering is that
you live on the periphery,
you will have to walk through
existing neighborhoods
in order to get to the
center of the city.
The plan is a linear formation.
Cumbernauld establishes the
first multi-level central city
apparatus, with great fare, and
enormously lauded by architects
internationally.
In the last page
of what I've given
you is the contemporary
view of Cumbernauld.
It's considered the ugliest
building in England,
and half of it's being
torn down at the moment.
It's on the last page.
Irvine is a linear town.
And Runcorn is
built on two hills,
with a figure eight
configuration for train system,
with the center--
this is residential,
residential.
And the configuration
is set by the topography
and by the rail system,
which meets in the center.
So these were all
propositions, which said, look,
there must be some
innovations which
are possible in the departure
from the conventional version
of a town.
We can judge the success
of these in prospect.
This was followed by
the mark three towns.
Here, the population
was 50,000 to 100,000.
The Mark Three towns were now
plus 100,000, up to 250,000.
And the most celebrated
of them, of course,
is Milton Keynes, which now
introduces a grid system
as the basic spatial
structure of the town.
An enormous increase
in affluence in England
during this time representing,
amongst other things,
an increase in the use of
automobiles, and the effects
in its thinking of
philosophers, like the American
from the University
of California
at Berkeley, Melvin Webber.
You'll read his writing a
bit later in this class,
arguing that community
without propinquity
is a new possibility, given
improved communication
technologies, and therefore,
another set of imprimaturs
need to be examined
before you decide
on priorities of pedestrian
walking distances, and so on.
Milton Keynes-- anyway, what
creates this enormous spike?
I could make another graph
on the blackboard, which
shows that Plato
represents 30,000
is the ideal size for a town.
Leonardo represents
[INAUDIBLE] 30,000.
30,000 seems to be the
lingua franca of town size
until about 1960, 1970.
What determines 30,000?
Why 30,000?
Why does it remain a generalist,
classical architecture
has remained as an attribute
of our performance?
Is it demographic?
The demography of Plato's
time and the demography
of the Renaissance
are already different.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: From the
Renaissance [INAUDIBLE]
through the plague epidemic
through enormous differences
in life cycles, and
so on, we end up
with whatever [INAUDIBLE]
at 30,000 again.
I don't know of
anybody who's actually
studied this phenomenon.
If some you are
interested in the research
to understand why 30,000 has
remained an ideal estimator
for new towns, until the
Mark Two British towns
decided they were too small.
Part of the switch to
larger size in England
is accompanied by
greater affluence.
Why do you need a larger
town when you're wealthier?
AUDIENCE: People want more land.
JULIAN BEINART: There
are more opportunities.
Milton Keynes now has
its own football club,
and so on, and so on.
The way land is rationed by the
market or by the state changes,
as it has in Russia, from
nine square meters per person
to what it is today.
More than half the
Russian housing
today is in the private market.
So I don't know
what the estimate
is of its current
square foot status.
These are fundamental
theoretical questions,
which few people seem to be
interested in engaging in.
What is conservatism
and innovation
as a phenomenon in the
decision about space?
Russia took a completely
different trajectory.
They had no history other than
a history which was miserable,
and about which nobody
wished to do anything.
They were in a fundamentally
primitive state.
Hannes Meyer was the Swiss
guy who took over the Bauhaus
after Gropius, was
a good Communist
himself, talks about
visiting Russia,
Moscow after the revolution.
He talks about Moscow.
In the Arbat, the quarter of
the city in which the wealthiest
merchants lived, only 16%
of all dwelling houses
were connected to
the water main.
It's a phenomenal
statistic, given
the wealth of the czarist
regime, and all of its courts.
And in the [? Prison ?]
[? Peratovski ?] region,
a czarist, working-class
area 0.6% had a water tap.
This is in 1918.
Let's talk a little
more about England
before we finish
and move to Russia.
The British New Towns
policy built something
like 28 new towns--
21 in England, two in
Wales, five in Scotland.
And according to a statistic
I've used for a while,
and I don't know
if it's correct,
1.4 million people live
in new towns in England
now, about 1/60 out of
the total population.
Much of the thinking
came from a couple
of what we now consider to be
relatively primitive ideas,
that Abercrombie's
plan for London
created a major investment
in a green belt,
on the grounds that agriculture
should be preserved close
to the central city.
Imagine that to be the
case of American cities.
I wouldn't have any
bananas for breakfast
if I depended on
agriculture within driving
distance of Boston.
Secondly, that nature
would be preserved,
and that would be a good thing.
And access to
nature for citizens
would be an advantage
in urban life.
Think about this--
Cambridge University
in England is
one of the great universities
of the world, if not
the most valuable.
Anybody who has teachers
such as Darwin and Newton
and a couple of others
could claim that category.
Cambridge controls the
center of Cambridge.
It's surrounded by a green belt
in which much development has
been frustrated.
Occasional development
has been allowed,
which is one of the problems
of the green belt philosophy--
that it's almost
impossible to maintain,
even in a very
diligent government.
In Chandigarh, for instance,
the sacred land north
of the Capitol Complex depicted
by Corbusier's drawings
of the Himalayas in the
distance and the Capitol Center
in the foreground.
When we did a studio in
Chandigarh, of our students
patrolled this area,
and saw all kinds
of signs of land being sold
and available for purchase.
The administrator of
Chandigarh was appalled.
He said he didn't know this.
So you can assume that even
in England, the administration
of public land in
large quantities,
as large as a green belt
around London, is difficult,
let alone open to
avenues of corruption.
Secondly, taking
out of the market
a significant portion
of available land
must have an effect on the
value of the land which
is not taken out.
So the abstract calculation
of cities saying every city
should have a green belt
is as much nonsense,
without taking into account
the particular economic,
socioeconomic context of the
city that you're dealing with.
They are, no doubt, cities
in parts of the world
in which the green belt would
be a reasonably good idea.
Off the top of my
head, some cities
have topological features,
like Bogota has a mountain.
And they're right up
against it, which prohibits
significant development.
Cities with enormous
topography have access
to natural vegetation,
and natural open space,
and probably don't need
a green belt as much
as a city on a plain.
My response is
simply, a response
to the large problem of urbanism
is never absolutely correct.
It's formulaic.
My advice to you is
always to question
whether it's appropriate.
Linguistically, city
administrators pick up words.
The biggest problem
of working, as I have,
in the non-European/American
world is not the cleverness
of what your ideas are.
It's how capable they are
of being put into place.
Try writing
high-rise regulations
for cities like Amman
in Jordan, which
we did after the Iraq explosion,
and the enormous transfer
of capital from
Baghdad to Jordan.
There's no working stock
exchange in Jordan.
It's a poor country.
And Iraqi money wanted to
build skyscrapers immediately.
The mayor, the new
mayor, asked us
to provide him with some
high-rise regulations.
And how do you implement
high-rise regulations
without a sophisticated
group of people?
Putting a high-rise
building in a valley
is different from putting
it in on top of a mountain.
And the topography
of Amman, just
like the topography
of Jerusalem,
is undulating all
over the place.
Secondly, does the meaning
of a building by Renzo Piano
have the same meaning
as a building decorated
with artificial cosmetics, and
Islamic symbols, and so on?
Thirdly, tall buildings in a
flat city are very important.
They stand out more.
Fourthly, the difference between
a hotel and an office building
is significant with
regard to what?
Come on, you're
working in Amman.
What is the difference
between a developer who
wants to build an office
building versus one who
wants to build a hotel?
Think about transportation.
How many people commute to an
office building every morning?
How many people commute
to a hotel every morning?
A hotel is revenue
neutral as far
as transportation is concerned.
An office building
is revenue active.
I'm just giving you a list
of the things that we listed.
The mayor of [? Arvan ?]
has no planning staff,
or maybe has an
assistant or so on.
What do you do?
He simply says yes or no.
Given the political
pressure on him to say yes,
when money is to be
made in a poor country,
how are you going to
expect a rational decision
to preserve the quality
of the built environment?
It's a depressing prospect.
It argues, on the
one hand, for wanting
to go for the few fundamentals
that you can't live without.
Transportation is one of them,
but the meaning of buildings
is--
Boston itself has difficulty
with the Design Review
Committee, which
John [? Lemonceau, ?]
who's now an Emeritus
Professor here, used to chair.
What can you tell an architect
colleague of yours about
why his building is ugly?
Anyway, enough-- the
British manage somehow.
Amongst the reading I
gave you-- and I want
to switch because we
otherwise we're going
to have to take too much time.
I gave you an article
by Lionel March
called "Why have new towns?"
It's a pretty fundamental
piece of writing.
Why do you think America has
not got a legacy of new towns?
Why are Columbia, and Reston,
and the green-belt towns
of Roosevelt exceptions?
Come on, you should
know this stuff.
You're the most
highly educated group
of young people in the world.
Guess.
Why Chicago did not develop
[? the state ?] of new towns?
Why has Los Angeles or
Phoenix just generalized
the metropolitan area
through suburban growth?
AUDIENCE: Because it takes--
I don't know.
I was going to say
something about it
taking a centralized force
similar to the state, not
the state.
[INAUDIBLE] think
that far in advance.
And with Columbia, it
was sort of like that.
And Columbia had the advantage
of being in between two
metropolitan centers.
JULIAN BEINART:
Yeah, I think that's
a good generalized answer.
One of the problems
about a new town
is that the capital that
you need to invest early on
returns its return only
after a long period of time.
Somebody's got to hold
the baby in the meantime,
while you are out for dinner,
if that analogy is any good.
I don't know.
The state did it in England.
The state controlled
all of the land.
First of all, the state
controls more land in England
than the state does
in the United States,
but given the authority that
the TVA had in 1933 onwards,
it could have built new towns.
It built Norris, which is
a small town in Tennessee,
but we have relied on private
development significantly more
than our national development.
We have no national industrial
policy, for instance.
You may argue as to whether
it's a good idea to have one.
And there are many
arguments both ways,
but in Britain, it was
acceptable for the state
to decide that an industry
should locate in the Potteries
area of the Stoke Valley
to deal with unemployment.
And the version of
that in this country
is under Clinton, the
idea of giving subsidies
to industries to locate next to
poorer, inner-city communities.
It was a policy which,
in extremis, was applied
by the South African
government to slow down
the growth of Johannesburg,
Cape Town, and Durban,
by giving enormous incentives to
industry that would locate next
to [? disadvantaged ?] areas.
I.e., you have to take
account of the diseconomies
of the location, and make
up for the diseconomies
of the location by subsidy.
This is not-- if BMW wants
to move to South Carolina,
or Boeing wants to build its
Dreamliner in South Carolina,
the United States'
democratic process
is not one in which the
state indulges itself
in that decision.
It will allow the
states to compete
in giving benefits
to any decision
that BMW or Boeing will make.
That Boeing decides to locate
in the state which is not
trade unionized, we smile.
I'm talking out of class.
I should shut up and just deal
with the British new towns.
The British new towns have not--
one of the other
paragraphs I could
have read from the 1946
report was that the town
should be balanced.
You get a similar
idea to balancing,
which if you remember
a couple of weeks ago,
I used in talking about
the Sunnyside Gardens
[? redband ?] phenomenon
in this country, Clarence
Stein and Henry Wright.
Lewis Mumford said you have a
need for balanced community.
That is, you need workers,
and elites, and artists,
and professionals
in one community.
Most of the immigrant
and unskilled workers
emigrating to England go
to the largest cities.
So the whole
Abercrombie argument
that new towns slow the
growth of established
metropolitan areas doesn't work.
The market is still functioning
in a way in larger--
you may say that
in a large city,
there's enough
variety in the market
to take care of more people
than you can in the new town.
My gut feeling is
that this is correct.
The range of rent per
square foot in Los Angeles
is probably much larger
than the restricted range
of rent in a British new town.
I throw these out because they
are interesting arguments.
You are going to be responsible
for making decisions
about the form of places.
Just this morning, I've
already drifted off
into lots of intricate arguments
about the relationship,
for instance, between land
economy and the form of places.
What are you going to tell
the government of Pakistan,
as I was asked, to design a
new town parallel to Lahore,
five years ago?
That it's a bad idea?
On what grounds
going to-- what are
you going to use for argument?
There's no theory.
This is the only class
in theory you ever going
to take, except perhaps
in social science.
Architecture doesn't
deal with theory.
So what are you going to say
to the governor of Pakistan
or the governor of Lahore?
Yes, it's OK.
This is land that the
army doesn't need anymore.
Pakistan is a
growing enterprise,
in terms of siphoning
off from India work
in advanced technologies,
and electronic communication
systems, huge markets,
available trained people.
Why not build a new city to
attract American enterprises
and into you know the story?
What are you going
to do about migration
to a new economic
entity in Pakistan?
A practical problem-- if
you create a new economic
opportunity like Chandigarh,
if you're Corbusier,
you keep on designing it as
if nothing is ever going to--
and mutilate his concept.
Fact is that people
from poor areas
migrate to limited economic
opportunities in the region.
And sprawl-- they are
called "squatters."
What do you say to the
people wanting to build
a new town in Pakistan?
How are you going to deal with
it in the planning of the town?
That's a big problem.
We'll ignore it.
We'll get the military to
pull down illegal housing.
Where are you going
to get a labor force
to do the lowest income work?
Seeing you have no decent
economic policy for the poorest
people in your country anyway,
what the hell does it matter?
This is real practice.
I'm talking about my
experience five years ago.
I'm not inventing this.
I raised the question of trying
to invent an economic system
whereby free land, or land
under some kind of indenture
agreement, could help
people build up capital
that they earned
in the new city,
that the economic engine
of capital creation
and establishment could be--
and it's been tried in
certain parts of the world.
And I think it's one of the
answers to the use of land
and the sharing of the increased
value of land in a city.
But I'm not an expert.
I'm only a teacher at MIT.
I've just been asked
whether I could possibly
do a new strategic plan for
Abu Dhabi, which I'm not
going to do, because I
haven't got the energy
and time to do it.
But just imagining how to do
a strategic plan for Abu Dhabi
involves taking into
account a number
of things, which I
don't think you'd be
allowed to take into account.
Number one is the real
ecology of the place.
I've done three projects in
the Emirates, one of which
was on Saadiyat Island,
where a ecological firm
from Philadelphia decided that
the island should be left alone
because it was an important
migration center for birds
from northern Europe moving
systematically to the south
in the winter, and other
important considerations.
None of that's been taken
into account anyway.
I'm sorry, I'm just
deviating from our sad story.
Russia is simpler and
much more complicated.
You have a couple of things--
there's no precedent
to build on.
All of the intense
rhetoric of Marx and Engels
said three things about cities--
capital cities are dying.
They must be an option.
Number two, integrate
the country in the city.
And number three
I can't remember.
Let me look at my notes.
Separation of city and
country, distribution
of population over
the whole territory,
destruction of capital city--
you don't do very well with that
as a kit bag of information.
When you're dealing with the
largest country in the world,
with 11 time zones from one
side of the country to another,
with a Marxist theoretical
position which focused itself
on the workers of the state and
not the business of a state--
it's the largely
agricultural region.
If you want to read a good
little book, "Ten Days
That Shook the World" is
the story of the first days
of the first Russian cabinet.
And this woman is given the keys
to the Agriculture Department.
She comes there.
She can't get into the building.
The lights are not
working, and she's
got to feed the whole
of the universe.
It's remarkable
that they survived.
However, there was an enormous
attraction given to the fact
that you had a new philosophy
which governed then.
The state controlled
all of the land.
You had a new, potentially
educated proletariat
who were educated to norms of
goodness, and social equity,
and certain givens,
which you didn't
find in the capitalist state.
And we're having to go
through this rather quickly.
The period of about
15 to 20 years
set up an intense speculation.
Given different attitudes
towards technology,
given different attitudes
towards the distribution
of society, different
attitudes towards urbanization,
none of which had a
set of researched--
the Russians had built
a garden city called
Kazan in the early 20th century,
which is relatively successful.
And Kazan appears as a basis for
some of the plans for Moscow,
I think the most, if
not the most of it.
And I think [INAUDIBLE] plan.
There are three
major institutions.
They're now private firms.
After the establishment or the
disestablishment of the USSR,
we took part with a group
called [? Lengi ?] [? Progore ?]
in a new plan for
St. Petersburg.
And [? Lengi ?] [? Progore ?]
was with the Russian Institute.
And the Russian Institute, they
had clients in Vladivostok.
They would fly through 11 time
zones to get to their clients--
an incredible apparatus.
They'd never worked on a
city problem themselves.
It's interesting stories.
Anyway, there are three major
academic practicing groups.
They all have names based
on shortened versions.
ASNOVA was a formalist group--
the capitalist individualist
prefers the horizontal line
and immobile column.
The socialist prefers the street
climbing, horizontal line,
the spiral, and
so on, and so on.
What is extraordinary in all
of this revolutionary rhetoric
is the significance
of the visual image.
The propaganda train--
I mean, imagine building
a propaganda train.
You're in a civil war.
You just about still
fighting with Germany,
and you paint a train to go
through Russia celebrating
the new idea of Russia.
The preference that people gave
to the visual impact of power
distribution-- you will see
it after '35 in the return
to what--
Marx was very impressed
by the Rubens paintings,
because they were large,
and covered enormous things
that you could identify with.
His version of the emotional
response of people to artifacts
was exaggerated.
Abstraction, which
was really very much
the platform of
people like Malevich,
and Lissitzky, and Chernikhov,
and all of these people--
those are great artists--
were competing not around the
social premise of the work,
but who could, as in
the ASNOVA group--
create a visual formula
which would emotionally
convince people that they were
in an alternative setting.
I don't know of
any other examples,
other than in Fascist
power principles, where
a certain emphasis on verbal
rhetoric was not very much use.
People tend to see with their
eyes without being trained.
People can't-- most of
the population of Russia
couldn't read.
The second group, the OSA group,
the group with Moisei Ginzburg,
and the [? Bach ?] brothers,
and the Vesnin brothers,
and [? Lissitzky, ?] and so
on was a functionalist group.
They say it's scientific
socialism and functionalism.
The ideological value of
proletarian architecture
does not lie in the
exterior forms, which
act as organs of perception, but
in the scientific functioning
and spatial organization of
the practical problems involved
in the practical
realization of socialism.
Khrushchev in 1957
said what a waste
of money it was for Stalin to
have wasted all of his money
building [? Lermontov ?]
University in the Palace
of the Soviets, and all
the shit decoration.
He said, if we stripped
those buildings of it,
we could have housed
another 300,000 students.
The third group
was of [? VAPRA. ?]
And they were also
a group interested
in the abstraction of form.
Amongst the OSA
polemics, there were
groups which fundamentally
are distinguished
between the attitudes
towards urbanization.
The sociologist Sabsovich
was an urbanist.
He believed that
the city was still
the center where human activity
will always take place.
He recommended the idea of a
pervasive network of new towns,
about 40,000 people each,
each town being totally
collectivized, each
[? evident ?] [? to ?]
[? sell ?] and so on, such towns
to be located next to industry
or collective forms.
The disurbanists were
a group of people
who believed in the
mobility of the individual--
light houses,
small-scale equipment,
linear settlements along roads
joining industrial centers.
They were very influenced by
the work of Peter Kropotkin, who
argued about the
decentralization
qualities of the electrical
grid and other emerging
technologies.
For them, an ideal
place was that you had--
there were apartment blocks
being designed according
to this formula, where each
person in the apartment block
had a cell of x
number square meters,
barely large enough
for one person,
and the rest of the space
for collective activity.
Or some of them
even had, in turn,
proposed internal
gymnastic tracks.
The idea of the
social condenser--
the ground floor of a
building by Moisei Ginzburg
had nothing other than
place to condense.
The vertical system had nothing
other than Fourier's interior
for people to meet
accidentally and to socialize.
The whole apartment
block was conceived
as a system of socialization,
as in Krushchev's
Microraion settlements.
Following [? Karmatzoff ?]
in Vienna,
an early environment broken down
to about 1,800 people per block
would form a collective in which
the socialization element would
be fundamental.
I'm trying to rush through all
of this as quickly as I can.
So for OSA, notions of
linear form based partly
upon the American example
of the conveyor belt--
"Let us take this storm of the
revolution in Russia, united
with the path of
life in America,
and do our work
like a chronometer."
That's Chernikhov.
Taylorism-- F. W. Taylor of
Harvard University, literature
about industrial
affinity and management.
Lenin exhorted his society
to make use of Taylorism.
Stalingrad tractor plants
were prefabricated in Detroit
by the Albert Kahn Company.
[? Forzazia ?] became a premise
[? Forderization. ?] "Men stand
still, but things
move," became a mantra.
The authors write, automobile
factory Gor'kiy was designed
under the supervision
of the Ford Company.
Albert Kahn, who is one of
America's more interesting
architects, his company had
a hand in over 50 enterprises
in the USA.
He was supposed to work
primarily for Henry Ford.
Interesting--
Albert Kahn's a Jew.
Henry Ford is an anti-Semite.
The Russians dislike Jews.
But somehow, again, you
have a complete breakdown
of any kind of thing but skill.
Albert Kahn is the world's
greatest industrial architect,
probably ever.
He provided things which
the Russian society
were willing to accept, even
although he was a foreigner.
And imagine Russia in
this post-Czarist state,
with a loose ideology,
which we're all
sitting in rooms trying to
say, what does this all mean?
And here's the United
States, churning away,
building Ford
automobiles in Detroit,
and reading about
Taylorism, and so on.
And the society is
coming closer together
around the production of goods.
As far as urbanization
is concerned,
it meant very little.
The linear plans for the
competition in Magnitogorsk
and Stalingrad,
and [? Ortestroy ?]
for the production of
cars, tractors, and steel.
The linear settlements--
linearity--
I wish I had five
minutes to talk
about the problems of linearity.
Linearity offers great
attraction to architects
because it's elementary.
Expansion is feasible because
you've got two open ends.
You can provide public
transportation system
along the line, where
it's most efficient.
The crossings of the
line are unimportant.
In the Stalingrad
plan, you have a park.
You have housing, a park,
industry, and so on, and so on,
like a complicated McDonald's
sandwich stretching infinitely
in length.
One of the most interesting--
I'm jumping-- one of the
most interesting competitions
in urbanism--
competitions in
urbanism are very
difficult. If you examine
the context of a city
as closely as we've been
examining them in this class,
you probably would have to do
a lot to provide a competition,
unless it's for a small
piece of a city, parts
of the inner city.
But a competition
for a whole city,
unless you're
interested in big ideas,
I don't know a successful
urban design competition yet.
One of the more
interesting cases
is the case of the la
Ville Vert competition.
Just after the
Revolution, the Russians
decided that they needed to
create a new town near Moscow,
which would alleviate the
workers from the strain
of working so hard--
that they could
come to this town
to spend a week
or two weeks just
dealing with the world
of fantasy, and so on.
The three winning
competitions were
by Ladovsky, who
built a town which
balanced trains and
automobiles, but did
nothing particularly else.
The second prize competition
was won by Moisei Ginzburg
and his colleague--
I forget the name
of his colleague--
who proposed the system of
ribbon roads and the train
system.
But the basic system was a
disurbanist proposition--
that people would have little
huts, live in the countryside,
connected by electricity,
and basically
living in the rural areas as if
they were free, like animals.
The housing was designed on the
basis of one person per unit.
If you were married, you had
a sliding door between the two
of the units.
You could transgress that
part as freely as you wished.
But if you didn't want to do
it, you could be separate,
and in an anarchic
sense, perhaps
choose another partner for
the time that you were there.
The most interesting example
came from a strange man called
Melnikov, who was one of the
most brilliant architects
of the modern period
anywhere, and one of the least
understood.
Melnikov did everything strange.
He said that everything
that the human being has
to experience in my
town is going to put him
in a different state of mind.
So he said, [? let us ?]
study sleep.
He said we sleep for
a third of our life.
I'm going to try to influence
the way people sleep.
So the interior is
units of sloping beds.
And he plays sounds into the--
Roxy Roth of New York
heard about this,
and came to Russia to meet
with Melnikov, to popularize
the idea of putting smells into
American radios and Radio City
Music Hall.
Melnikov wanted wild
animals to roam around,
so that you could really
be in contact with nature
in a serious manner.
How serious, I don't know.
The intimacy between a wild
animal and a human being
is pretty serious.
He had a whole bunch
of other things.
He had an Institute for
the Reform of Character.
He had the virtual--
the edge of his city was
almost like the walls
of an ancient town, where
people could go on long walks
and meet other people.
You enter his town by train.
The train stopped
in the station.
I'll show you the slides.
You get out of the train
and you sit in bleachers,
and you are socialized.
You're given large, dramatic
presentations, and so on.
It's an extraordinary
place from its interest
in the individual's experience
throughout these two weeks
there.
In relation to nature,
he used solar energy,
had a solar energy pavilion.
This was long
before solar energy
was appropriate in our society.
Let's look at some
of illustrations.
I'm sorry for this
compressed version,
but there's very good
writing now available.
And the [? Talkov's ?]
basic book
is still a very good source.
So let's look at some
of these images--
Abercrombie's plan for
London, the clearing away
of the space around
the center city
and the creation of
a green belt. Next--
I'm going to go through
these very quickly--
the typical for Mark
One town, one center,
microcenters in
the neighborhoods.
This is Welwyn Garden City.
Next, Stevenage, and the
center of a Mark One new town.
Next, Mark Two--
Hook, a linear city with
a linear center space,
built above a tunnel.
And as you can see, the arrows
pointing in the upper section
pointing to the fact
that you have to move
through others' neighborhoods.
This is social engineering
through the form
of distribution of the housing.
Next, Runcorn, one of the
more revolutionary towns,
based on a public transportation
route in a figure eight,
meeting in the
center of the place.
Next, and the
great Cumbernauld--
these are the
diagrams of the center
which fascinated the
architecture world so greatly.
Next, on the left, you can
see the architecture use
of airplanes and helicopters,
which Frank Lloyd Wright used.
I don't know why it's
important to animate the sky
in the depiction of a town.
Everybody does it,
but nobody suffers
the disaster of Cumbernauld
as Cumbernauld did.
Next, Irvine, the linear
town, linking through--
no, don't change
that, thank you.
And an earlier version of
Milton Keynes on the right,
the distributed, gridded city.
Next, Milton Keynes,
the diagram on the right
indicates the increase
in affluence--
leisure, sport,
automobiles, highways.
The plan of Milton Keynes
is a sectorial plan,
in which the grid
system is carefully
designed at one kilometer
by one kilometer.
One mile by one mile
would have created
the need for separated
highway connections.
The volume of automobiles
at one kilometer
restricts the system of
connections to a traffic light.
Next, another principle here
is an interesting principle
for those of you who are
interested in these kind
of things.
In architectural
construction, if I
create a truss
between two points,
I can load the system anywhere
because the system will take
care of the load distribution.
The same principle
is attempted here.
It's going the wrong way.
OK, there we are, thank you.
The system is designed so that
the system, no matter where
you locate, can be taken care
of by the transportation system.
In other words, you're
creating the design
of the town, a robust enough
system of moving infrastructure
so that any loading position--
say an industry which
is to locate here,
another industry here--
all of it is taken care of
by the infrastructure design.
Next, here are just two examples
from a Venezuelan project
called El Tablazo, which
is the same firm which did
Milton Keynes, designed
at the same time.
The whole idea is that
the center of the town
would be a zone for
squatters, that the incubation
requirement in the
middle of a city
heightens the educational
input into these people,
and they can then
migrate from here
into an existing
surrounding neighborhood.
It was never built.
Next, Russia, hell
on Earth, the image
of contemporary
capitalist industry--
this is from Miliutin's
book, Sotsgorod in 1919,
the use of visual material
in the celebration
of the new republic.
Next, Ernst May of the German
architects and his institute,
who did the distributed
plan for Moscow.
Corbusier's plan
on the bottom left.
Next, [INAUDIBLE].
This is one of the more
interesting plans of Moscow,
[? Kirov's ?] plan.
Basically, if a city
expands, the tension
is in the environment around the
area which it's expanding into.
What do you do with that?
You see all of these
projects are uncertain.
You either have a green
belt. You restrict growth.
If you do growth, this
one tries to capitalize
on the communal environment
at the edge of the city--
a huge infrastructure of
sport, recreation, open space,
and so on encircles Moscow.
The only version
of this that I know
is in Havana in Lenin
Park surrounding Havana,
where you have, in a sense,
an encultured green belt
of modest size.
One of the [INAUDIBLE]
[? Moscovit ?] plan,
which is similar to
Alan Smythe's plan--
that is to distribute roads
and rail systems all around
in fingered form,
in linear form,
and to have small interventions
in linear form along these.
Next, this is [? Shushev's ?]
plan, and the 1935 plan,
which became the orthodox
plan, which Moscow's
followed roughly ever since.
Next, this is the
Ladovsky's plan
for the Ville Vert competition.
Next, this is Ginzburg's
plan on the left,
mainly with [INAUDIBLE],,
linear road systems,
and green filled in between,
in some version between a grid
system and a dotted system.
And on the right is the
diagram of Melnikov's plan,
with an elephant in the center
and a bull up at the top.
Next, here is these
entries to the city.
This is how you
enter into number 15.
You are socialized
on your entry.
What that means,
god alone knows.
Here's a bedroom, which
is articulated in relation
to the sun, and into sleep.
And here's a solar
pavilion on the left.
Imagine designing a
solar pavilion in 1919.
Next is extraordinary.
That's one of his drawings on
the right for the new Ministry
of Industry.
And this is in--
sketch from 1924, Exhibition
Pavilion in Paris,
which was built, but not quite
as dramatically as the diagram.
Next, the OSA group, in all of
their scientific formulations--
here are the two
based on linearity.
Next, the plan on the right
is of a linear distribution
of a connection between
separated settlements
and a linear system
in Stalingrad.
The drawing on the
left is interesting.
One of the great
skills of urban design
is the skill of diagramming.
You need to be able to
diagram very well in order
to convey your intentions
to your colleagues,
to other people, and so on.
The diagramming system here
uses simple forms of description
to animate the big idea.
Next, here, you can
see Leonidov's idea
for distributed
disurbanist environment,
of huts connected and urban.
Next, just a few
glances at housing.
Here in the diagram of this
housing project on the right,
the ground floor
is, as you can see,
occupied with
people condensing--
condensing, playing
sport, playing.
Here on the left is a
diagram for projecting
the power of the
[INAUDIBLE] [? interior, ?]
the central position, which
links to a number of floors
through the building.
Next, Moisei Ginzburg's
modern apartment block.
The ground floor and the
roof are totally given over
to communal space, and
the floors in between
are small and compartmentalized.
Here's a project for a
residential environment
combining a number
of the features
of these intellectual groups,
the advertising of the building
giving the visual prominence
to the shape of the building.
There's a wheel.
I don't know if the
wheel articulates
the idea of the elevator
going up and down.
Next, this is the
projection by one
of these groups for the
housing in the Magnitogorsk
competition.
This is, in fact,
on the right, what
was built as the result
of the competition.
Next, this is Melnikov's
cinema in Moscow.
Imagine making three separate
buildings out of a cinema.
On the left is
one of Corbusier's
lesser-known buildings, this
[? Enthroysius ?] building,
a 1929 building for the United
Workers Councils of Russia.
It's now the Bureau of
Statistics building.
Next, the Dom-Kommuna building
on the left, the social housing
built under the
Dom-Kommuna system.
On the right is a club.
Next, these are
just two diagrams.
Here is Tatlin's famous
Monument to the International
on the left.
On the right is
Melnikov's the entry
into the Pravda competition.
All of them involve the building
moving at different rates.
In the Pravda
competition building,
the separate cores
of the building
rotate the building
at different speeds.
It's the invasion of
architecture by movement.
This Monument to
the International
has also rotating
geometric forms
which move at different speeds.
It's much like when
the Queen is in London,
there's a flag on
Buckingham Palace.
You will know when
Congress is in session
by watching the speed of the--
more like an urban
thermometer, somehow.